and clarity okay so so I work at NYU and
the math department and the Center for
data science and I'm looking at this
problem from like a data science point
of view so hopefully this will settle
something so we're interested in
optimization problems that come from
data science or machine learning these
problems are usually and be hard but
np-hard statement allows the worst case
instances of your program and sometimes
every SEC algorithms do a good job in
typical data and so this there seems to
be a gap between the theoretical
guarantees and the practice so we're
interested in understanding what is the
structure that makes the algorithm work
and the biggest science philosophy is we
don't care if a protein can be hard we
just want to solve it sometimes you can
find exact solution or a very good
solution for np-hard problems in a
significant subset of the problem
instances like in compress sensing
there's this thesis that says that
clustering is difficult only when it
does not matter that is also
controversial but we're trying to see
what can we are in this direction and
this data that we're looking at is not
other serial it's just some data so when
looking at theoretical guarantees for
clustering from like a data science
point of view you have this
probabilistic models for your data that
you can analyze your algorithms in
expectation or in high probability
like what Dustin deal with the
stochastic a ball model and we mixture
of gaussians but real data is not random
it doesn't satisfy your models so may
not be useful for a practical point of
view even though understanding how your
algorithm performs in these models it's
a sanity check it's useful because if
you if you know that your algorithm
doesn't even work in the simple cases
you cannot expect it to do something
gold in a
in a more real case and the there's also
these deterministic conditions for clear
ability that I was just mentioning
earlier and he has a few papers
analyzing them and the this this notion
of like closer ability for data are nice
to look at but sometimes they're hard to
test like Center civility or
perturbation robustness and they're
maybe not realistic for the data that we
have so data cannot maybe I know so
maybe you're clustering objective is not
actually just like finding 10 classes
but it's more complicated you have a
harder problem that comes from your data
and you your idea is that ok I should
only do clustering if my data is is
class level but how can you evaluate
that your data is class rule how do you
know if you're getting optimal class
links from your algorithm and k-means
plus plus doesn't get it and I'm sure
I'm gonna show a way to give it in a
data-driven way so in this talk I'm
gonna talk about k-means clustering
there is this this I or if M K means
plus plus that everyone uses and it's
amazing and and Dustin just explained it
and and then there is this semi definite
programming relaxation that has
guarantees that also we just saw and
healthcare entities for specific models
and in my talk I'm gonna talk about a
technique that leverages the guarantees
from the semi-definite program to
produce a sub linear certifier of
approximate optimality of solution and
this requires no modeling your data so
linear in the number of points linear
time in the number of nodes in the
number of points that you want to
cluster yes
so without open mind so okay so we have
the k-means problem again so you want to
minimize the sum of the distance square
between your point and the centroid of
the cluster here we are in a clean space
so this these pyramids a be harden in
the plane and this there's Deloitte's
algorithm that which is so you choose K
centers and at random you assign each
point to close the center your compute
the center's and then you do the again
until convergence and k-means plus plus
is just a smarter way of initializing
this same procedure
so the k-means plus plus is fast is very
easy to implement and it's widely used
and in my point of view I think they
hide the worst problem that it has is
like given the output it doesn't tell
you how good a solution it may be so it
may converge to a local minimum it may
converge to a optimal you don't know how
do you evaluate how good the solution is
and this is what I'm going to do so we
have this semi definite relaxation that
we just saw so punch into it but it's
like this optimization problem where X
is you're looking for a matrix of this
form that is going to indicate your
clusters and you solve it with this
optimization so my goal is to find a
lower bound on the k-means value so i
run k-means plus plus i get some
clustering and i want to know how good
this is so I'm gonna say if I have a
lower bound saying that well the value
of your class ring can be at most
something then if your k-means plus plus
value was very close to it then you know
this for most optimal yes
because okay yes we're gonna we're gonna
look into that yes
so the so far they only lower bound for
the chemists values that I know is they
want that is given by the K means plus
plus or did you know taper in 2007 that
that says that if you have two points
that you want a cluster and you consider
the the random variable W that that is
the value of the k-means plus plus
initialization so just like in his plot
like the first first step then the the
value of the k-means is gonna be one
divided by the number of points x they
can use value and this is going to be
greater equal than 1/8 locator so
expected value of peace initialization
so so these this tells you that the
value of the kidneys needs to be greater
than this lower bound this is a lower
bound for the Kimmie's value
so this lower bound let's let's test
what is lower bound tells you you will
run it in the enemy's train the set will
take last ten clusters and we run
k-means many times and we obtained that
the lowest k-means clustering value that
we obtained was 39 and this lower bound
tells you like 2.15 so my question is
can we get a better lower bound on that
so the idea to obtain a better lower
bound is quite simple the idea is that
so there came in subjective if you have
this these points and you have four
clusters here the k-means objective is
going to take every point and you're
going to sum the distance square to the
centroid and then you consider the
average of that and if you take a sample
like a sample of your points then what
happens is there for the sound from each
point to the new center is going to be a
like smaller in average
so in the sample the distance to the
centroid because the the previous
centered is also a feasible point from
the optimization problem so this minimum
minimum is going to be at least a school
that's very small so in math terms what
it's saying is that the value of the CP
my sample is an expected value is what
in general the value of the CP in the
sample is smaller than the value of the
K means in the sample because it's a sub
relaxation and then I'm saying that the
expected value of the K is in the sample
is a lower bound for the body of the
Kimmie's in the whole set
I mean my goal is to establish that
expected value of the SVP in the sample
is greater than son found weights small
p-value so that's my Michael to to give
a probabilistic lower bound on what is
the value I mean say yourself that you
would are you claiming the different
soil the sample optimally and look at
the cost it's gonna be lower bound to
the optimal solution to the whole
dataset yes in when you divide by the
number of points yeah in expectation in
expectation right because they can wait
so what do you mean expectation well
where do we take the expectation here so
I expected over all samples of value in
the sample right but then expected about
what's up above the value of the sample
is that true remaining anything no
because you'll be cluster II we should
pick a difference if they're like
something is like a pitiful it under
something I know what she's claiming
yeah no but they have a paper that shows
that people just do it with expectation
of a sample just original no fix
expectation takes care but I mean with
no assumption is it is it good do you
think it's always like this model equal
and you'll say it's equal to let me
they're like some extent some [ __ ] to
get equality now you feel over the
points against one place in one with
someone else if you don't something that
one would go down okay points if you
miss one point people timidity go don't
think it's good but we have seen okay
points
zero
so let me show you how this lower bound
performs so here this blue line over
there is the kidneys plus plus value
this is the caimans plus plus lower
bound with the expected value teen
sensation and what we will be plotting
in red is the value of phase CP in the
sample and then we take this expected
value so over these experiments
that's like thought the maximum that's
expected like you and that that lower
bound you can just take a hundred points
and it provides a pretty good lower
bound on the value of Kem's and and if
you fix the number of the samples that
you're gonna use then these runs in your
time so you can just see how many what
if you do this experiment you can just
given number time budget you can decide
how many samples you want to do how many
experiments
so they they lower penalties it's great
clothes and so for these data set and
they do useful things that you can run
it in anything I said you don't need to
have a model and that would give you a
lower bound and you can just write a
like an sophistical test for these like
a multicolor proximation certificate
like if you take your data you take a
subset before me later and photos this
test and then you you wanna insert like
you wanna through with certain p-value
that I'd expected on your face EP is
greater than some bound you can just
design this this iPod is using for
example Markov's inequality and it tells
you what is the p-value of your explain
like when you take these
yeah so
any questions
I think you can you can have bounced on
how close is this logo to the optimum in
terms of the size of a sample and then
the bound on the border context data
that would be great yeah and I think
that would improve this result I feel
very out of it okay means value or the
STP you know they came you I say the K
means valuable the optimal solution for
the something how close it is to the
optimal k-means in terms of two
parameters the size of the sample and
the values of the smallest voltage
enclosing the data so the game here is
to get a lower bound on the true thing
and we don't know how to get honest
lower bounds on k-means values other
than by passing to a relaxation like the
SDP
so in your case we're assuming that you
can solder the thing in the thumb
packets yeah yeah so here if you cannot
solve in a sample optimally but you can
run this this relaxation that would give
you a lower bound yes exactly
and and you can see for example what is
the bomb that you obtain for a mixture
of gaussians model so so here then um
the number of points that you need so if
you're a doubt ensign in RM and this is
a simple model where you have two cows
Ian's with identity covariance then you
say the number of points that you need
scales like a log N and the bound that
you get is like three times optimal so
it's a three with with with 99%
confidence
and that is just only running like
Stalin experiments so if you put more
experiments and I mean this result is
definitely not optimal just something
that you can get you can get a three
approximation and you can extend this so
you don't use Markov inequality you can
do something smart there like some
concentration and and then in that case
then you can consider okay so you can
consider some okay so in order to use
this this concentration bound you need
to know about on the value of the ACP in
the sample and you can just make it in a
smarter way so did you take the minimum
of the value of beta T and the value of
the chemistries class for the analysis
so this number is smaller and you can
get a lower bound still and giving a
computational time but you can optimize
the number of experiments and the number
of samples to certify the largest lower
bound that you get for a possible
p-value or you can optimize the best
view I do for a given bound in the same
way and that is something like that you
can do on your data just I want to see I
want to show that my data is like I want
to see how how good this lower bound is
for this specific data
and and this and this concentration that
we use here will actually give us a an
additive bound instead of a
multiplicative pump so we can know that
the the value of the k-means is in the
in the case of the image of thousands of
kale cake options you can say that the
value of the k-means
is within like a k plus v of optical so
this is our review this is good in the
when the regime when the dimension is is
large yes I'm sorry what it's like when
you scale the scale the points by 2 what
happens yeah yeah yeah this is a assumes
that the covariance is identity yeah
okay and then it scales with the borders
yeah
so I want to show some plots so this is
an example with the mixture to thousands
so here we have a histogram of for the
values of the SDP in the samples with
the number of samples is equal to 10
here we have okay this is X the for like
the frequency of 3 is like 5 times on
the frequency oh well it's like 20 times
for the for the value of TCP and and
this is the value of the SDP in the
whole set and this is the value of the
ACP expected value of the SDP among the
samples right so when we increase the
number of samples we expect that the the
value of the SDP it expected value of
testing samples will get closer and
closer to the expected of the value of
teh city in the whole set so this
concentrates like that and we actually
find that the expected value of DP is
smaller than the value of TCP in the
whole set so that's a that's something
that we don't know how to prove but it's
something that we observe and like from
Eastover may need a distance I only used
specifically on mega dataset we've never
seen it not satisfied ok and then and
then for example this so here we have
for some datasets that are used in the
k-means flash paper we have the lower
bound that for these number clusters we
have the decay interest was minimum over
several iterations this is the lower
bound that we obtain with this technique
this is the lower bound that we that the
comes from they came in stress plus with
a expected value thinning sensation this
is the number of experiments that we
perform and
and we optimized for a specific time
budget so we say what is the number of
experiments and the number of samples
for this specific time that Jess and so
here with what we have said is that the
actual bond that we obtain is sometimes
it's very close to the value pick means
plus plus and it's much better than than
they or other lower bound but sometimes
in this in this example what happened
was like the the SDP solver that we were
using did not output something that was
feasible so when you so in many of these
samples the ACP solver didn't output
something that was feasible so we have
to round it to this whole point of the
program in order to produce a lower
bound and in this case when you round it
the lower bound that you get is not
meaning so it's an issue of the solver
but it is an issue that happened with
many soldiers that we tried so and these
have and these datasets are supposed to
be not actually class level so yes is it
well supposedly that's their that's
their yeah how many points
and the intrusion 50 so so okay so so
these can tell you what that your data
is clatter oh but you cannot tell you
that your data is not class at all right
and so okay so so someone open problems
that we're looking into so the first
thing that I mentioned was that expected
value of the SCP in the sample seems to
be a lower bound for the value of the
CPA and we don't know how to prove that
and also we don't know if this is true
for other recipes and in general if we
can do certifiers of these loads of
lower bounds for other recipes may be
very just hope but here we are using the
structure of take a means a lower bound
that you that you mentioned so we don't
know if that would be true for other
problems and and say if we can
approximate like how an approximation of
the number of mistakes and so the body
of the k-means and just do smarter
sampling that what we are just doing
and this is it they have some references
but in fact they should have only left
this one that is the one we discussed
just now
thank you sir Tamiya you compare this an
algorithm that you have with this
algorithm that we have it for clustering
and hierarchical clustering called
affinity clustering that is the
algorithm actually was in its previous
here and there is a Google research blog
when it touches
Tonga's if we are essentially on Google
data it is currently in use maybe I
don't know 10 15 places that we let the
main cluster in that word and I forget
it worked at a scale that means 12
trillion edges we are collecting less
than a minute and I think you should
take a peek at it essentially know what
is then what is the objective that its
optimizing for I mean essentially the
idea that I mean do you want to come in
cluster I mean it's also the very like
that the one that we have done it in
particularly like this you have several
results out there but the one that we
had if we had a labeled data we just
essentially stricted labels give this I
will then be comparing these k-means or
other thing that even in a smaller data
actually out-beat those high order gaps
like single linkage or i mean average
but I think a doctor I mean it's not the
question problem I mean you have labels
you try to find sets which are home
again homogeneous with respect to the
labels and you don't know how that I
believe it was generated right so for
any clustering algorithm I can give you
data for which this clustering algorithm
we look optimal under this criteria for
the mountain I mean couldn't you give
give me two algorithms tell me which one
we want to be the other I'll give you a
data center which didn't generate these
keys are can I can use that Cochin
I didn't generate yeah I'm tweaking of
theory and practice when I claim
something I know what I'm talking about
so that works in practice I mean lots of
this objective that's actually
outperforms lots of previous algorithm
and you may tell me try yourself if you
don't believe it
just write that but as I mentioned
there's a cool research blog on it
affinity clustering and it is the main
clustering algorithm at Abuja so I mean
so eventually you have to think I mean
that literally that could become because
some of the days no problem he want to
see I mean practice which I'll so we
have some theoretical things about the
essentially algorithmic are good I mean
the receive and I've got the basement
the proof coil go to the port of call me
who is finding surely algorithm you know
if nothing killing is that's like
coastal is cool scholars injected what
is quite not finger details and we are
comparing if you stinking linkage
husband and hapless vintage I vetoed
perform its it look a lot essentially I
mean take a look at it I mean you wheel
it
I must look quite surprised actually
these days I'm sorry
yeah I didn't believe it either she got
balls and this is like the current then
the other people try that to your
kidneys or also for the huge data so I
think that is I mean Steve we are
thinking more about this to get more
theoretical inside voice works for Bell
but it would be I think nice to me
compare lots of this kind of STP
algorithm is those algorithms
organization
somewhat constrains you controlling to
the STP to try and get it closer to them
because I think that's a gap that you
can't get around even if you make a slaw
yeah so for example if you so we are we
are relaxing the protection into the
indicators with with this SCP but a
priori you can do like a higher level
relaxation for the for that set
waving projections are always less or
equal to the identity and that doesn't
appear in our SD theory limitation so
you could probe a tendency no but I
think that the solution that you obtain
has all the eigenvalues smaller than one
so this is somehow following the kind of
between theory and practice and in if
you only care about the feel even
instead of doing the SDP something
completely there k means over the sample
is still sublinear because the size of
the sample is independent of the size of
the valence even if I saw would force
and find the optimal of the sample and
still constant time because the size of
the sample is independent of the size of
the data it only depends on how well I
want approximate but but in practice it
may happen that if you do a larger
sample and you run the ACP you get a
better thing that the smaller sample and
you just run the k-means at the same
time but yes yeah
this you trade-off right way yeah
approximating the approximation but
power of the approximation right but I'm
just saying if you look at it from so
ethical point of view it's quite
something
yeah okay that's Rachel the intrusion
data set of samples